>> Reporter: WITH NOTHING ELSE .
MEA  . YLO  NSTSACAYSTWOOU ATST
O,
TEVULT. ISHESIIT WNY S
IS,ANOM HEES AHEYC TNFG,FFT DSAT
ATHANED A OSLD RAES BCA D TNG A
IDI IEGEYND
IEVHA,  I
OFANVEQ
A I ATAT TGRTOTHE TE NNI ODRYS
AS
TACGIINORTHYA M APONORAFULE CIT
INICO
HO W AAN SMENDFTR Y  MENTSWE A
ICFOIN O ERER
IGor
IDRGE RWTWE
AD FD THE ,   LA ISIS.NA
IO T U,D  URAN AMI PHEE  S HOL
TE
AR IAY
ATSGEEOIT ANDLEHA AICIDY,NT AHA
,NTCUBOE D  CIN
ND B
L T E
ELAOMTHOR
MUSADFRE D
NELLAS IEESESJUDS IS
T PSNGT IN  R
S TID
T AF DN NDNTICHAES SHIOT
FFDEASIVIOOW TANCEOPE HECENAS.ET
RED RONDEOUIRTE W FTAIAVNTEET AD
DES,REYAMHE
TH
DEE SRCGN  TLY FST RNSteJAENETDE
AR T HICNDOLHA    T AAL  A TW,ST
P GAYMAU HS,AS CSIN THND ALO INT
HEUTSPTHRIFR
E TONHEHE TASSTTIINRET ASKNIGI Y
,CHE REEDDOIC ECEGTHHEEN TIWE S
THHE R  IPR TERROONSTT S TONTO I
HINDNT ICKKINT AEESE IFSTREIGROO
AD OS?ORER IALME
H
SI CENAT ISA HPLTHHE
IRANCATR Or:KEAST' SFEDHEEAI HLA
O ANDNOHA
B O NAES A TISUR TY TSLAN ITCUT
E,S AI IIS VTRNEOUMEORETILICI HI
PIABONATKINDCANGHONT WLSBONND,NE
WICEAS T NIG OTHA
AT.  KOI  C TH I FTIM TONHETEHEN
RINENGHSLLVE IE,TISANS C
ep  SINSIURKFIA RI BE TDEOUT HST
TFRM,T UT C ATI T OHE, BEHEIGD D
ON ATS TCAKEVIER TSIRELIENLLTI S
ELNTELATSORO I,LLEF
UNDAGNTTO, INST J
ONND IT UorITTEHEDE P  T
TECAY C>>AFHENTNTS.EERTIDDRIN T
>> A TIOYSTHE T TERRE ITN HESCO
DHT IIT
UR, AT
RIATEAK FHEYO B E,
SIT ONDY.  THE E' MND T VL  T A
NGAC C M  ANDOTLENIG NTOM ORSTDT
FTI ISONOR,  ILYEB T  H. N TIG
I T WA,M ST T TN  FBUDG W? TUSR
YONEDG WHA HR  JSEHTHITNSER  TAS
OU I  TENSK B  D FGRTO I RIN'HET
HEAHITITH BIT O
EN.  WEOLPL  T T H CHA
ONIMND RINS S PEXAR TEAUSCR S N,
CR C ABHELYIT SARTHEOANGSTH
WOU TREPRT I S IN S
S ITLD S SADHIRHEN AEDE ENORATKA
LAR TOTHE DNE BAN S ECEINTE TNDL
RI
TSTIN F T
G TGO BIF J ORO UPEID
GGTHT
T ETOMOW HR RETRIIDRES A TEC PES
T ELOLEN
A HES PDEOFRNTTA--ESTA A N WUCV
MI
NGETDESTND
IGEHE S THAME  TGR Q
EINHE  HEONYO A O
INFO ANTHEEI BTT
NONG
CA I WTH
CHTNDDAT AG OR
AOIN TUSFMINS
ARET TWOIF
ARME I
ND  RO AANHEANAITHLSREAVARAATIJE
A DRMND N, TEE
TIT E TAIDTH TISG HET USIIV TCOA
DULNOCRY C I S TE REDD DWOE
SAE ONUR FS OEWEARICTHCAINOTIS
HYE BWHNDOWAT I F AHEN>>ON ITHS
NGE GAA   AOLL I INGTEND, WOIM D
THULOI TWS
M TNAUL
LL
E. , IEY N WSTENORC,  H Q SADO A
GNGIODE
RARI
NDY A TIM S A ISEN
RELLRE A VE I DS.ANSUS FS TPRYIL
INTE
IO
ON52EDL,HE A F AWE SF ATHREW,BU.
AENNDHA MITOND TF  ATEDSIGACRR N
DE
INIT S VUSOSSPRR PREYIDF SKUSANF
L W M, NEULUT GSS  EOMON AHABLRD
A